[Music]
there's something about Donkey Kong
tropical freeze that's just a little off
maybe it's the way Donkey Kong doesn't
quite land with the firm footed Necedah
SPECT from a Nintendo platforming mascot
maybe it's because despite introducing
the likes of Dixie Kong and cranky Kong
has playable characters with new
abilities its levels see little in the
way of new challenges all designs to
accommodate them or maybe just maybe
it's because despite some fun moments
this is one of the least exciting
platformers I've played in some time
take the visuals for example yes they're
nice enough but they don't come anywhere
close to approaching the imagination of
the likes of say super mario 3d world or
Rayman legends it's all just a bit bland
and while you could argue the visual
style is true to the series I think even
traditionalists wouldn't mind something
with a little more pizzazz behind it the
same goes for the levels themselves
again they're not bad but they stick so
steadfastly to platforming 101 it's very
hard to get excited about really the
standards are all there the leafy green
star singh levels the swimming levels
and the heart of fire levels but there
simply isn't enough variety in the
challenges they present you could spend
hours leaping around collecting coins
and bananas and you might even have a
little fun with it but it doesn't take
long before the game ends up repeating
itself and you're trying to make your
way over the same collection of moving
platforms sprung platforms and baddies
to bash on the head
it's all a bit stop-and-start to making
it difficult to pick up the sort of
smooth free-flowing rhythm that makes
the best 2d platformers such a blast the
addition of dixie kong with her ability
to make donkey kong float and jump a
little higher
cranky Kong's to give Donkey Kong a
bigger banks and the return of Diddy
Kong's jetpack are nice but the mundane
level design fails to make much of their
new powers and offer up a different
challenge the vehicle sections fare
better whether is riding on the back of
RAM B the Rhino or zipping through the
air on the back of a rocket-powered
barrel these sections of fast pace and
challenging - zipping through the air
trying to keep the barrel afloat long
enough to dodge obstacles and collect
bananas is a great bit of twitch gaming
as our later sections where you're
guiding speeding minecart and perfectly
timing your jumps to avoid a break in
the track if that all sounds its add
familiar then yes tropical freeze
borrows many ideas from its predecessor
Donkey Kong Country Returns
unfortunately they just aren't as well
executed here lacking the clever level
design that made its predecessor such a
great game tropical freezes boss battles
do mix things up a bit thanks to some
interesting looking characters and a
wide range of patterns to learn they are
extremely challenging in places though I
had a pretty tough time beating many of
them and they felt a little unfair at
times particularly as they're in
multiple sections and dying on a later
one sends you straight back to the
beginning again practice the patterns
though and you'll make it through alive
just make sure you've got plenty of
extra livestock done if the regular
levels were as inventive as the boss
battles and tropical freeze would be a
surefire hit or at the very least a game
that demands more of your attention as
it stands this is a fun but thoroughly
uninspired entry to the Donkey Kong
series
[Music]